قد تكون مفاجأة للسائحين
ولكن مدينة نيويورك محاطة
بالشواطئ وأعتقد أن Rockaway هي واحدة من هذه
الأحياء القديمة التي تختلط الآن مع جيل
جديد
من راكبي الأمواج والفنانين
والثقافة والموسيقى ونحن في  مركزها
أنا ستايسي لاستو كبير المحررين في شركة CNN للسياحة ، وفي نيويورك ، تقع
شبه جزيرة Rockaway
في
كوينز على بعد حوالي 16 ميلاً من
شقتي ،
ويمكنني الذهاب والعودة في نفس اليوم ، لكن
أصحاب الأعمال هنا يأملون أن الناس
مثلي
سوف تجد أن الأمر يستحق البقاء في
الليل ،
مرحباً ، كيف حالك
أنا أحب الإقامة في الفنادق ولكني لم أقيم في أحد الفنادق
منذ
مارس ، لذا فأنا أتحقق أيضًا من هذه الرحلة التي
استغرق بناؤها في Rockaway سنوات
وتم افتتاحها مباشرة في  وسط
الوباء ،
لا يزال المكان محجوزًا في الغالب مع
السكان المحليين ،
نخطط لكل جزء من هذه المساحة ليكون
مكانًا ترحيبيًا للمجتمع
وأيضًا لزوار الحياة
بدءًا من الردهة التي نريدها أن تكون
غرفة المعيشة المجاورة
هناك  لا يزال الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يرغبون
في معرفة المزيد عن Rockaway ،
وأعتقد أنهم بحاجة إلى معرفة مدى
سهولة الوصول إلى
هنا والآن لديهم مكان للتسكع
هناك الكثير من الأشخاص هنا ، إنهم
أشخاص رائعون ، والطاقة رائعة
هناك  لا يوجد سبب يمنعك من البقاء
لبضعة أيام ،
فإن أصحاب الأعمال هنا متنوعون
يتحدثون كثيرًا عن سندويشات التاكو في
شاطئ روكواي ولكني مهتم أكثر
بتجربة شيء جديد
[موسيقى]
ما هو الشيء الذي تعتقده حقًا في قائمة العلاج الكيميائي
تجسد كلاً من
المطبخ المصري واليوناني ،
تختلف الفلافل تمامًا عن أي
فلافل مصرية أخرى أو أنها غير مصنوعة من الفول
كما نستخدم الكثير من الأعشاب مثل
الأعشاب الرقيقة ،
ولا نستخدم أي علب أو أشياء مسبقة الصنع.
في مطبخ كيم
ونفخر به كثيرًا ويتعرف عليه الناس
ويعرفون أنه
كان المجتمع داعمًا للغاية
ليس فقط للفايما
لجميع الشركات الأخرى
، كانت وسائل الراحة في فندق روك أواي
رائعة  بأسعار مناسبة ،
لكنه ليس الخيار الوحيد في المدينة ، لذلك
أنا أيضًا أتحقق من
فندق المد والجزر الصديق للميزانية
في يوم تسجيل الوصول ، تلقيت بريدًا إلكترونيًا
يشرح الكود إلى الباب الرئيسي في
الغرفة التي سأكون فيها  البقاء في
الغرفة والرمز إلى تلك الغرفة ،
إنه اتصال مجاني وكان دائمًا على
هذا النحو ، نعم لقد كنا بالفعل على هذا
النحو منذ البداية
، لقد أفادنا حقًا خلال COVID
لأننا كنا دائمًا غير ملامسين ،
لقد كنا مشغولين جدًا بالفعل بهذا
الصيف أكثر ازدحامًا من الصيف الماضي ،
والناس من المدينة في الغالب
هم من يبحثون عن
بضعة أيام حيث يمكنهم الهروب من
شقتهم الأصغر والحصول على مساحة جديدة
بالقرب من الشاطئ نوعًا ما مثل
الإقامة على الشاطئ ،
إنه عامل الجذب الرئيسي للمناطق الصخرية
في  شروط إجازة سهلة في مدينة نيويورك
شاطئ Rockaway
رائع ، لقد خدشت السطح بالكاد
على واجهة الطعام
وبسبب ظروف المحيط العاصفة ،
شاهدت ركوب الأمواج لم أشارك
عندما أعود ، أنا بالتأكيد أتلقى
درسًا في ركوب الأمواج
وتناول المزيد من المحار
لك